se nos ha dicho en la clase de álgebra
que si tenemos una línea este tendrá una
razón constante de cambio de iu con
respecto a x es decir que nuestra línea
tendrá una inclinación constante y la
inclinación o pendiente pendiente se
define como el cambio en este
triangulito es la letra griega beta y se
usa para expresar cambia
el cambio entre el cambio en x y si
tratamos con una línea esto es constante
esto va a ser constante
constante para
línea recta una línea
para una línea lo que quiero hacer en
este vídeo es demostrar esto usando
triángulos similares pongamos dos grupos
de dos puntos aquí va el primer grupo de
dos puntos y cuál es nuestro cambio en x
entre estos dos puntos
bueno aquí lo vamos a poner en el eje x
estos son los puntos sobre el eje x por
lo que nuestro cambio en x es este
y cuál es nuestro cambio en y bueno
ahora vamos a ver estos puntos sobre el
eje
y este que también lo puedo poner acá es
el cambio
ahora pongamos el otro grupo de dos
puntos aquí abajo y hagamos lo mismo que
en el anterior vamos a marcar los
valores de cada punto en el eje xy en el
eje y entonces aquí están en el eje x
que el cambio en x lo voy a expresar por
conveniencia aquí abajo
el camión y aquí está en el eje y y este
cambio en yo no voy a dibujar acá lo que
les quiero mostrar es que elegir estos
puntos aleatorios y este cambio en de
arriba con respecto al cambio en x tiene
la misma proporción que el cambio en
aquí abajo con respecto al cambio en x y
esto lo haré usando la similitud y una
vez que demuestre que estos dos
triángulos son similares todo quedará
demostrado recordemos lo que significa
ser similar
la similitud se cumple si y sólo si se
tienen ángulos correspondientes iguales
entre los trigos
ángulos correspondientes
congruentes
aun con diferentes tamaños en los lados
estos triángulos son similares pues los
ángulos correspondientes son congruentes
o iguales aquí voy a dibujar dos
triangulitos aquí en diferente posición
este más o menos así vamos a ponerle los
valores a los ángulos
y aun con diferentes tamaños en los
lados estos tengo no son similares pues
los ángulos correspondientes son
congruentes o iguales
lo genial de los triángulos similares es
que una vez que establecemos que dos
triángulos lo son entonces la proporción
entre los lados del triángulo también
serán congruentes o iguales es decir que
la proporción de este lado con respecto
a este otro lado
va a ser igual a la proporción de este
lado de este otro triángulo con respecto
a este otro lado de manera que pueden
ver porque esto no será útil para la
demostración que queremos hacer ya que
si estos triángulos son similares
entonces la proporción entre sus lados
correspondientes será igual y como estos
son puntos arbitrarios la demostración
servirá para cualquier grupo de puntos
en la línea tenemos que demostrar la
similitud lo primero que sabemos es que
son triángulos rectángulos estas líneas
verdes que estoy dibujando son
horizontales así que estas dos van a
formar líneas paralelas
ambas son horizontales y esta línea de
arantxa es la transversal de manera que
si tenemos líneas paralelas y una
transversal que las atraviesa podemos
decir que estos dos ángulos van a ser
iguales
de manera similar vamos a extender estas
líneas verticales de mis diferencias en
ambos triángulos y son líneas paralelas
ambas son perfectamente verticales
y de nueva cuenta nuestra línea naranja
va a ser la transversal entonces si
tenemos una línea transversal que
intersecta dos paralelas los ángulos que
se forman con estas líneas van a ser
iguales y ya habíamos dicho que son
triángulos rectángulos así que este
triángulo de aquí es un ángulo recto de
90 grados y es igual entonces acá vamos
a demostrar que estos triángulos tienen
exactamente los mismos ángulos internos
por lo tanto ambos triángulos son
similares
ahora si ponemos las etiquetas a los
lados de ambos triángulos aquí pongo a
aquí ve aquí sé y aquí de podemos
afirmar que a / b esta proporción es
igual a la proporción entre c y d debido
a que son triángulos similares dicha
proporción es la definición de pendiente
el cambio en g entre el camión x así que
ésta será constante a lo largo de
nuestra línea pues estos fueron puntos
aleatorios y con esto queda demostrado
lo que queríamos